so peter
so why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry
to bother you sir please we saved half
the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir okay stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did i was in my bed
in kingston which is now my brother's
bed uh i had played golf with my dad i'd
lost i went upstairs i was very upset
because i'd lost and i was obviously at
the time very nervous to find out and
anxious to find out whether i was going
to be spider-man or not so i was
scrolling through instagram constantly
refreshing the feeds trying to find
information or inside information but
marvel had posted a photo of spider-man
and they essentially said go to our
website to find out who the next
spider-man is so i'm like naturally
really disappointed though because you
didn't get a call yeah i didn't get it
called so i'd assume that i hadn't got
the job i
um i went to the website i didn't even
think about that i just was like i'm
gonna just check just in case right and
i used i was really upset about it
obviously i opened the thing and it said
we are proud to announce that our new
spider-man is from southwest london it's
tom holland i was like what the
slam the computer down
i'm like running around the house
and i um
i'm like screaming my brother's like
losing their minds because you know
they're all part of the process with me
that is so sweet and then harry rightly
so said like bro like they've probably
been hacked because there's no way they
wouldn't leave it to harry to be like
i don't believe it
there's no way you so i taught my agents
this was very early in l.a like it was
it was in the morning they were up they
were like we've heard the news we're
trying to figure out whether it's true
or not and then i was in my garden
pacing back and forth kind of you know
over the moon with the news but also
worried because i didn't know if the
news was
real news
and then i got a phone call from a plus
one number right 3-1-0
kevin feige called me and he told me
that i was gonna be spider-man and it
was crazy
wow
hello peter
yeah that was an interesting occasion
actually i was flown to atlanta to shoot
for civil war captain america civil war
with the russo brothers my first scene
was a fight scene with captain america
himself so as you can imagine as a young
fan that was kind of crazy but the thing
is is they'd already been shooting with
my stun double marvin had been shooting
for like six or seven weeks before i'd
even be cast and he was much bigger than
me and you guys know how long it takes
to make the suits i mean it takes up to
14 weeks to make a single suit um so
rather than making me my own one they
just said they were gonna tailor
marvin's to me
now marvin is like six one he's big
and i am not 6'1 and not very big
so when i went into the room i saw the
suit hang in there on the hangout i
asked them if they could close all the
mirrors so that when i put it on i could
see it for the first time when it was on
so now i'm putting the muscle suit on
i'm putting the helmet on
i put my arms through the whole thing
and when they opened up the thing
it was like
it looked like
a scrotum like it was like a saggy
gross like foreskin spider-man suit
because it wasn't tight at all it was
just like loose and gross
scrotum suit
not the scrotum
suit i want funko pop to make spiderman
yeah so that's what that's what um it
was like and it was very disappointing
but you know now i've had many of my own
suits that fit perfectly
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly little you know it's
funny because um the first movie i was
uh in it for i think a total of three
minutes
the best three minutes no such thing as
small parts impactful three minutes okay
just small actors um
so yeah i am
yeah
i know we're actually very so i'm just
saying i'm i'm neither
nice
um no it was um it was actually it was
so for the first time uh being on the
first movie i just was blown away
because i was there and all this stuff
was happening but i didn't really get to
be there very very much you know so i i
didn't really get to be a part of much
of the action it was really i think
yeah i don't know i don't i didn't i
never absorbed it all i think it wasn't
even even remember that one time we had
to wake up at like the butt crack of
dawn and go into london for that for the
big oh yeah
we're like we were running outside of
the freaking tower of london right at
like five in the morning right from
something that obviously would be later
put in in visual effects and such things
and i was like this is like the craziest
thing i've ever done in my life i'm with
my friends i am screaming and running
from drones that aren't there yet right
and i'm in london i am in a historical
landmark right and this isn't amazing
i was like people have gotten their head
chopped off here yeah
this is like
tons of people
so uh yeah it never really sinks in
every time i feel i don't know it feels
like a dream steal yeah absolutely i was
just really excited to go and travel you
know the world with all my friends you
know and i think that we didn't really
understand that we'd be part of the
action a bit more
and i think for me there was parts where
we were running from like big explosions
and things like that so it was very much
a lot of firsts for us again i think the
whole idea just like just remembering
all the things we did and like trying to
wrap my mind around traveling the world
and doing all these things with all
these fun people i think that it really
opened up my world in a sense that like
i was very closed and very much not
really worldly so really getting to work
in prague and in venice was like in the
most beautiful places it really i was
really fortunate to be there it was like
a really big european vacation as it
were so
um
get them really confused they're like
homecoming far from home no way home i'm
like which one is far from home
far from home and no way home yeah
it's too close together
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker i mean this film definitely
explores uh how important peter's secret
identity is because obviously at the
opening of this film it's revealed to
the world that he is spider-man and that
comes with its you know a whole plethora
of problems i think annie's and he's a
villain like everyone thinks he's a
super villain but
the thing that really makes spider-man
tick is the fact that peter parker has
so much humility and i think that's what
kind of sets him apart and why people
really love him as a superhero and
because he has so much humility it makes
him an easy target for
super villains because they can
basically snatch up his friends and he's
always going to do the right thing he
doesn't mind sacrificing himself for the
people that he loves so it's definitely
something that's very important i know
that when they told us
that they were going to reveal it that
all of our reactions were like don't do
that yeah that's a terrible idea please
don't do that the story's going to
change but in turn it was a great idea
because it gave us so much creative
freedom to kind of find new aspects of
these characters that we already know
and love so as a creative standpoint
from a creative point of view it was
really helpful
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes ah
eyes on me
uh because both of you i felt both
yeah um okay so some of the greatest
moments um i cannot talk about
for obvious reasons so my second third
and fourth greatest moments
i will have to pick from to watch i my
favorite one of these movies and i feel
like i'm not biased because i'm not in
it very much is homecoming i just love
being able to see like little us yeah
and and see and see you know peter
what's special about that movie to me is
that it's like it really gets to explore
peter just as a kid peter parker we
often forget is just a teenager and i
think that's the most teenager we've
seen him ever so that was special and
the scene of you guys in the car with
michael keaton is one of my favorite
scenes of
all time and then i would say my
favorite one to shoot
other than you know events
would be things i can talk about um i
just think anything where we can do
stunts together yeah is always really
fun anything where we can do a scene
together i i try to be the mom of the
group i try to hold us together and keep
us focused but
what can i say uh my first scene with
rdj in civil war will forever be
something i'm so proud of because i just
remember how like nervous i was that day
you know i'm very lucky now that when i
come to make these movies you know i
bring all of my friends with me my hair
makeup artist my costumer my dialect
coach my security guard my brother
they're all my friends from home but
when i went to do that movie i went by
myself i was like 18 19. so to to see
that play out the way it did was awesome
i love the scene in end game where
captain america with that amazing like
swooping shot where captain america
catches the hammer and he's like
avengers assemble because evans was like
four or five people down from me and the
direction was as soon as he says
assemble everyone then screams and
charges towards the enemy but because he
was so far away i couldn't hear him say
assemble because he says it to himself
so he went avengers and then i just went
and ran off by myself
i was like i had to like i got like 30
feet and i had to turn around and like
walk back to like all of my childhood
heroes and be like sorry guys i got that
wrong
that was a highlight for me it's tough
to choose one specifically because
everything that i've done has been super
special to me because i've never really
done film before spider-man i would say
the first day that i worked on the film
and i'd say the first time we all really
hung out together is probably all my
favorite moments in my life and again a
lot of the cool stuff that we get to do
in this movie is probably some of the
highlights of my career as well so yeah
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too
don't
it really did feel like the trilogy was
ending you know the last day of shooting
for us was incredibly emotional and i
think you know we all went into this
film kind of unsure as to what the
future of spider-man looks like um amy
has come out and said that there is this
future trilogy but we're not you know
that is it's a conversation you know
blessing we're talking about what the
future of spider-man might look like
whether or not we are involved in that
future we are not too sure yet i think i
speak four of us are saying it'd be
pretty cool yeah but maybe we should
take a little break who knows but i do
know that on that day it was very
emotional john was very emotional aim he
was very emotional and it was fun it was
an amazing day and i will never forget
it look there has to be another win
there isn't
there a danger to our universe
[Music]
you're not gonna take this away from me
while the world tries to make you choose
you